[Music]
slightly before my teenage years I
developed a problem I was in and out of
hospital 17 operations I was told I
wouldn't walk again properly let alone
we have be able to do sporting
activities especially things like
running I was going to be registered
disabled at one point because it looks
so hopeless that was an incredibly
challenging time
[Music]
definitely know what if like to stuff
for myself
so I can relate to it with other beings
whether they be human on earth
[Music]
it's not means when you've been told
you're not gonna walk to get out be out
there do it now
that's never been moving and this is the
one race they have to pay insurance for
repatriation if you die this is not a
homogenized race that's destructive in
order to make it nice it's scary you
know you walk in there and you see
people you don't lift each other alive I
am trying to do something positive with
my running I'm not just out I'm a per
trophy or thinking I need to get my time
down I'm doing this with a reason and it
isn't any of those things in the Sahara
Desert one of the most extreme races in
the world takes place marathon two saw
blade the marathon of sand traversing
over 250 kilometers across sand dunes
mountain ranges dry Lakes and abandoned
villages of North Africa marathon de
Soleil is roughly the equivalent of six
marathons back-to-back competitors are
required to be self-sufficient carrying
all food and necessary equipment over
the course of six days to reach the
finish line available water is carefully
rationed at checkpoints throughout the
days and nights are spent in open-air
tent bivouacs along the route with
daytime temperatures reaching 50 degrees
Celsius the threat to human health is
very real in previous years runners have
died in their attempt to complete this
grueling event it has been called the
toughest footrace on earth well you
strike me as a very sort of unassuming
self-deprecating personality who
appreciates your your privacy and your
anonymity so I'm wondering what the
experience was like for you to see your
story writ large on such a gigantic
screen with all of these people here
it's the first time I've seen it is you
know it's kind of emotional bit painful
sometimes that the desert bits they're
always just funny who know how
ridiculous the whole concept of that
race is and yeah like did I do that
dream but I obviously did do it cuz
it'll blow and I said photo flopped but
you know yeah it's just a complete
whirlwind I've done nothing special I'm
nothing special I've I've literally
where does this self-deprecating nature
come from I don't it's not actually I
truly believe it and looking at the
vastness of the problem I'm trying to
address I and I realize that I'm very
insignificant and it would be wrong for
me to not stand by and do all that I can
but it never seems to be enough because
it has to say it's just so much more I
want to do so much more that needs doing
and I'm got time to sit back and
congratulate myself because I've
literally got nothing to congratulate
myself over but you know these are
little battles the war is not one and
that's how I feel
[Applause]
fiona is she's so pure and she's just
doing it like everything from her heart
she's not defined by a physical
condition
she doesn't define herself by her
extraordinary running she does this
completely selflessly
for her and passionate belief about a
pekin ism and about her animal century
part of what makes her so incredible is
that she's just so humbled her life and
her work with the animals with us
Sanctuary that drives her it gives her a
focus for her running for so many
reasons I want fiona to succeed in her
running in her advocacy I think
sometimes people look at individuals
like Fiona as like oh they're superhuman
maybe she does have some genetic
abilities that have helped her but she's
got an incredible amount of will and
she's a great example for what you can
continue to do throughout a lifetime I'm
interested in hearing a little bit more
learning a little bit more about how you
think about the connection between
running and the advocacy work that you
do that's so important to you how did
that come about and how do you sort of
contemplate how the running serves your
greater interests well yeah I mean I
decided with the runnings I don't want
to do anything kind of 80%
it's got to be full-on bearing in mind
the pivotal core of my life is 450 plus
rescued animals that I care for so if
I'm gonna do something I'm detracting
from the time I'm spending with them I'm
taking energy away from our body that I
could be spending on them so I've got to
make it worthwhile
and the reason I just became very very
frustrated obviously when we got the
sanctuary back in 1996 I saw okay this
is great but it's addressing always the
symptoms not the cause so I can take him
like 400 animals I could have 4,000
nothing most if I go to space but what
about the billions and billions of
animals out there that I can do nothing
to help physically these animals are
fine the ones that I care for they will
always be fine you know they're
obviously the predominant force in my
life but I wanted to do something to
help those I you know the bad press
immediate it was especially given back
in the 90s towards veganism it was
either
maligned or just ignored and I saw well
you know I've been
vegan all these years since I was six
years old I'm not like unable to get
offers to - you're looking like I've
been dug up from somewhere I I want to
be able to do something to promote my
lifestyle in a positive way
and I think people forget that at that
time there wasn't social media you've
got to kind of have to don't do
something to justify getting any fresh
so I kind of thought well I haven't got
any money and I'm not particularly good
at anything I'm sporting and the reason
I picked marathon running was it
literally it was tree if it was going to
do it at any time you need two pair of
running shoes you could do it alone and
also there was the kind of semi many
ready-made platform in that paula
radcliffe back in the UK was doing these
from buoyantly good marathon time so
obviously there was a heightened
interest in marathons in the UK at that
time and I thought if I could kind of
jump on the back of the publicity she's
getting that would kind of its
familiarized people with the event it's
been billed as like you know the
toughest kind of it this is a plain road
running endurance event in the athletic
calendar so if I could kind of use that
and and do marathons fairly well then
that would be a free publicity for the
sanctuary because we don't spend
anything we've got no budget for
anything it would get free advertising
for the sanction because when you win
racers people say you know what you do
for a living
I'll go animal sanctuary I don't do it
for a living but I do run an animal
century and also just really an
opportunity to people are interested in
how you've won that race know how you've
done well in it you can say by the way
I'm vegan
and that's the reason back in 2004
people don't know that we've got a big
running club in new UK I think vegan
runners is now the biggest running club
in the UK by membership I started that
with a guy called Peter Simpson back in
2004 because I was getting
elite starts I was getting offered
places in races asked to go and paid for
and he said you know obviously at the
time I was running for vegetarians and
athletics
because that was the only affiliated
club they've got anything any relative
to what I wanted to promote but I said
well yeah for sure I'll run for that
club but I'm a vegan and I would like
people to know that when I run past them
or I beat them I would like them to know
that I'm vegan and so it's a real hard
job to affiliate a running club in the
UK than it was back in the states but
Peter did all the planet paperwork and
the legwork and I did the running back
then and that's how faking runners were
started and it was at a time like you
know when you were going to the London
Maris and that's you know not the
biggest in numbers Berlin's the biggest
in numbers but major major marason in
the UK one of the five majors that were
at the time and you you're on the elite
start you set you know 45 minutes ahead
of the elite men in the main race and
you just it was just basically an
opportunity to run 26.2 miles through
the streets of London which are closed
with crowds everywhere focusing on these
few female runners me being one of them
and handle data see on your vest is
beacon that's basically why I've done
the running I'm not interested in
anything else but foremost in that word
but what's really interesting in your
response what comes across what I what I
gather from that is a strong sense of
self belief like you'll say oh I'm
nothing special I'm not that talented
etc but clearly there's a drive or a
sense of purpose that is underscored by
a belief in your ability to compete at a
level that would be sufficient to get
this kind of attention right yeah I mean
I just literally watched the runner that
used to look and think why are those
runners up there and I'm back here I
want to be up there with them and I'll
do what it takes to get there I clocked
up very quickly and like the London
Marathon I don't want to be running in a
cage like to it for three hour bracket
on the green star I want to be up there
on the main start with the good runners
going in the boss with the other elite
athletes and being out there with them
because that's the place I felt like I
belong there no not particularly I still
don't know never fell up along there
I've actually gone along to these races
and oh my lord when I'm actually walking
to the start of the elite race
Berlin with a hologram precisely I'm
literally checking out the opportunity
and thinking that guy in the Superman
suit he looks quick you know I mean I'm
clearly not no confidence runner and I'm
all the way I'm going to start saying
you know I wish it an excuse to come
work that I didn't have to go and it's a
real weird thing with me but I get on
the start line
and it's this Fiona goes she leaves me
and game on Fiona appears and I'm
willing I couldn't hurt another living
being back and Stanley distri out to
myself she doesn't brag about anything
she does and that she just gets on with
it but what she does this is quite
remarkable really the beauty about Fiona
is that she's taken care of you know
hundreds of animals on her sanctuary and
then she's training and she's you know
competing these grueling events Fiona
she says I'm not really a runner now how
can somebody who runs at 238 marathon
call themselves not really a runner
I mean she's not she's a really good
runner she's a really good runner it's
kind of a funny story with a running I I
don't like it I like talent I lack
ability but probably the strengths I've
got is that I actually do actually
recognise that but I don't really know
too much about running I don't really
care that much about running
I just care about the results I can get
from the running I have always felt
quite embarrassed when I'm invited to
these mega races and people are looking
at me thinking and you're you know what
are you doing here kind of thing and I
know I don't look the same as everybody
else and when I tell people you know
I've got like eight place in it I'm just
at a marathon or like top 20 in London
and Berlin and that great notes lawn and
these are the biggest races in the world
these are not for messing around with
people are like flabbergasted well
Keegan did a beautiful job of
documenting the pageantry and the beauty
and the sort of epic nature of doing MDS
but I think you know washing movie a
couple times but what really struck me
watching it this time and what I think
at least to me and I'm interested in
your thoughts seems to be the most
difficult thing that you ever did was
going from auto coma and suffering that
injury and
five days later running that marathon on
Antarctica not sure if you're even going
to be able to run to winning that and
breaking that record so how did you
recover like what was that like we went
off to South America and I have to say
if I'd have known what I was letting
myself in for a question whether I would
have actually gone it was so horrible
and I'm forever grateful that my mom
actually went with me and witnessed it
because she if she hadn't I don't think
she would have believed it the other
color volcano marason is extreme in a
very different way to the ice marathons
it's one of the highest marathons in the
world so you start at 14 and a half
thousand feet and you've only got 11
percent oxygen so about half what you'd
have it at sea level and that convinced
myself that it wouldn't be too bad
running a marathon at 14,000 feet
altitude
I really haven't given it that much
thought running at altitude think
especially for someone who comes from
sea level is definitely a challenge it
is very very extreme I think more
extreme and potentially more risky than
the ice marathons you've got to contest
with the fact that you're running at
altitude but you're not kind of runny
you are battling very very bad terrain
about 28 K I rolled my knee on a stone
or whatever it was I don't know I just
throw my name slip I knew I damaged it
badly the minute I did he I just thought
okay I'm gonna have to walk I'm gonna
have to do what I've got to do to finish
it's not gonna be pretty
and it really wasn't if I had just been
trying to do this for myself I wouldn't
put myself through it I have to say that
but I wasn't doing it for myself so I
did
[Music]
and I remember laying in the back of
this ambulance 14,400 feet up side of a
volcano in the Atacama Desert thinking
how the hell am I gonna recover from
this the doctor has just told me that I
am NOT gonna run again this year it was
November November the 14th how the hell
am I gonna run in Antarctica in five
days yeah I mean it was really really
horrendous I was having some angst with
the race to organized there only didn't
want me to go to Antarctica and so it
was a brilliant opportunity he'd
actually organised the Atacama race so
it must have been my from heaven when he
saw me literally my mom saw me too she
was in a race car just keel over with my
knee and when I got to the finish I was
very very fortunate one guy who was
helping with the race he saw what had
happened and he insisted cuz he spoke
the language rather he actually insisted
the doctors give me an IV pain relief
because otherwise I don't think I don't
know what would have happened but
literally it was just a complete
disaster I don't I still don't know how
I did that in Antarctica I literally
hobble to the start we went to Punta
Arenas wait fly to Antarctica and I had
to walk around well to hobble around
Punta Arenas looking to buy fine a shop
that sells those walking poles because I
thought I'm gonna have to walk and I've
even got these great be walking boots
and I thought it's two laps and I
thought well if I start and I tried to
run and then I can't run and then I go
to walking poles and just have to walk
around but it's bleak I mean you kind of
forget when you can rely okay thirty
four thirty five to six minutes for a
10k you tensioning how long's 10k gonna
take me and then you start looking you
watch right in MDS and again the cosy
two hours and you think oh my god you
know so he takes a long time to walk 30
miles in Antarctica and I started at the
back of the race and there was some
Japanese guy and he wasn't wearing a
Santa suit not but he got one of those
jokey Santa suits over there top of his
running stuff and even he kind of went
off into the distance and I'm kind of on
my own thinking oh Lord you know I'm
good after how long's this gonna take
its gonna take
and how will something at this pace and
I don't know I just kind of got warmed
up the pain kinda left my body I forgot
about it and I just thought do what you
can and I really don't know where that
wrong came from I just something on the
start line I I'm just so blessed I was
in so much pain and I remember being in
Santiago seeing other runners arrive to
fly to Punta Arenas that hadn't been in
the atacama race because I've been the
only fool that had decided to combine
the two so it's like you know if I
thought it was a really good idea and
I've been told that loads of runners are
doing bones feeling me not be a problem
and I am the only one and I've got this
angst when the race director who was
making my life an absolute misery and
the sort of having to go down there and
just not be able to finish the job that
I'd started was pretty brutal but the
funny thing was that he put every
obstacle in my way and if honestly it
was all worth it to see his face when I
cracked oh my gosh she's here again the
vegan runner woman coming and she's
gonna win the race but I don't know i
don't i don't know whoa I don't enjoy a
role you know I know I'm no good at it
and you know I mean I just want to get
it over with quickly you're not gonna
give up on that story
absolutely true I I enjoy the fact that
I can do it because there are many
people out there that can't so that's
kind of insulting to them but I'm always
in such a hurry with the running I
literally literally fitting it in I mean
people think you're in a hurry in
general yeah I mean I'm a firefighter
too and I I do that in spare time just
you know prevent income and a bit of
diversion from what else something so
literally I'll be one minute I'll be
bombing up the fire station in my
nightie and then you know get driving
you know get driving a pump from been
out for four hours and I'm thinking when
I'm over there running it so I literally
am that person is stomping around a half
looking for the elusive stalks that's
gone missing just to grab it and go and
then students that get back running
stuffs off and I'm just in another mode
probably actually helps because I don't
actually get time to contemplate how
awful it's gonna be when I'm out there
running there's stuff that needs to be
done all the time
yeah animals to see to
medications to attend to there's
maintenance to do there's a list of jobs
as long as your arm the thought of
having to do all that work and then go
out and run 25 it's not even just like
oh I'm just gonna do a nice little
country jog it's appalling speed work to
have to thing or an appalling 20-mile
road run and then come back and as soon
as you get back to have to then start
the evening jogs which is like bringing
all the horses in getting the buckets
right ya know even though you know we've
lived together 24 years I have no idea
how anybody can fit in let's bring
Keegan into this so Keegan this is a
very interesting choice for your third
movie your first two movies cowspiracy
what the health preserve established
yourself as this provocateur in your
collaboration with with Kip Anderson
these are movies that crossed over to
mainstream audiences and and really
created a lot of conversation around
these ideas that you're passionate about
but this is a very different kind of
movie so why this movie what struck you
about Fiona what compelled you to to
document her journey yeah so one Kip and
I were doing a fundraising campaign for
cowspiracy Martin Fiona's partner
reached out or maybe was Fiona directly
and said hey we heard about the film
looks amazing let us know what we can do
to help out and so I looked up who these
people were and I said help us you know
how can we help you
and the response to Kip and I got four
cows piercing what the health was
phenomenal but I was constantly hearing
this
yeah well I'm an athlete I do the X sort
of training and you know I could never
be vegan and I thought that can't be
true there's people like patrol there's
these ultra endurance athletes who are
breaking World Records we need to do
more to promote that and Fiona had been
in back of my mind for a long time then
I spoke to one of our executive
producers Cheryl Greenberg and she
talked about how the vegan community is
predominantly female and yet women
aren't really highlighted in the vegan
movement it
the male faces in the male names and the
male organizer heads of organizations
that are really promoted and that there
needs to be more emphasis on promoting
and elevating women in this movement
because it is a female dominated
movement I thought hey if we can combine
those two things promoting women vegan
women breaking the stereotypes of
veganism holds you back from any sort of
athletic achievements then you've got
something powerful and Fiona takes all
of those and then being a hardcore
ethical vegan on top of it which speaks
to my heart so this perfect and also you
really couldn't ask for a better
character for a documentary than Fiona I
first met Fiona in 2014 she came into
the shop and she was just this whirlwind
like she was absolutely mad as a box of
frogs I'm not sure I can describe her in
any other turn she is absolutely
extraordinary and what's really
extraordinary
she doesn't look extraordinary I heard
her bursting heart rates like 30 or
something
it's so low that they're like are you
even alive she just doesn't seem to to
stop I don't know how she does what she
does so she runs this Animal Sanctuary
with 400 or so animals she trains like
maybe 100 miles a week she's just so
dedicated to what she does and she did
she doesn't do it for her you know and
she doesn't for the animals and for
other people and you know she's trying
to promote sustainability when you first
meet her you've got no sense that you're
talking to someone that's extraordinary
and one of the reasons is that she
doesn't self promote she has no sense of
actually how fantastic she is what's
interesting about the movie among many
things but but what struck me which I
did in real I didn't I didn't notice it
the first couple of times I watched the
movie is that you don't even hear the
word vegan until you're two-thirds of
the way into the film is that a
conscious decision yeah that's a
conscious decision if you watch any of
the films that I've done you don't hear
the word vegan until 40 this is the
earliest film
here is 43 minutes in what the health is
like 47 minutes and cowspiracy is like
an hour and 10 minutes in you really
like what Fiona's done you really have
to pull people in to a story before you
can introduce them to veganism because
people they're so resistant to it it
seems so extreme to so many people so
you have to really kind of drag them
along get them interested why why did
you run in a cow costume why you know
why am i interested in this movie with
it just as vegan you're only gonna
appeal to mostly the vegans so yeah I
was definitely a conscious effort so how
long how much time did you spend with
Fiona what's this a period of time that
you guys hung out to do this um total
probably about a month and a half two
weeks and in January in 2017 two weeks
in the Sahara Desert
ten days in the Sahara Desert and then
another two weeks are not even not even
about a month total total time over the
course of a year and and going into this
obviously you you're familiar with Fiona
story and you have an idea of what
you're getting involved in what did what
what occurred that you didn't expect
like what did you find out about Fiona
or this world you know this subculture
in which she lives and thrives that you
were not originally aware of I really
wasn't aware of how humble fiona was I
knew that she was humbled because
everything I had seen in red but I
didn't realize that it was - this like
heartfelt level that it wasn't like a
facade or like trying to put on you know
to be cute in a humble sort of way this
is very genuine this is who this person
is I find that really refreshing I think
also for an audience - that's amazing to
see there's a lot of huge egos in sports
and and I love sports documentaries I
can watch the sports documentary about
anything I mean literally race car
driver boxers soccer players and I'm not
into sports at all but these stories
were always people they want to be the
best in the world but for what it's like
so they can be the best in the world
there's nothing else other than that or
a paycheck and then to have somebody who
strives to be the best simply to create
a platform to talk about compassionate
living it's like that's that's the
documentary I want to see so I really
made this
before myself for that and and again
that just that humbleness that lack of
ego because it's a selfless was I think
one of the most shocking things about
making it mmm-hmm I had spoken to the
other runners and there was almost like
an overconfidence to them
fiona was really refreshing because he
or she was touted as one of the elite
runners sharing with me in all honesty
that she was terrified just as I was and
I looked at her like how can you be
terrified so we're laying there you know
I caught him just like staring up at the
tent ceiling going this is gonna be
brutal and she's like yep it's gonna be
really hard I came in like six and a
half hours later and she hugged me and
she just said I am so proud of you and I
was like really like you've been laying
here for six hours waiting for me to
finish she was like yeah but I think you
were the toughest she's so incredibly
strong and she kind of denies it in
herself but she's so willing to
acknowledge it in others honestly like
I've never seen someone so strong and so
so humble
you strike me as a not only a deeply
compassionate person but somebody who is
who has a vast reservoir of empathy and
this sensitivity to suffering and
perhaps your you were born this way you
can see it in every frame of film and
the way that you interact with these
animals that you care so deeply about
but I'm wondering if there's a
relationship between the suffering that
you endured as a result of your your
injury with your your knee and the sort
of process of recovering from that if
that there I mean Keegan you serve tip
your hat to this point in the movie but
this connection between what you endured
going through that and how you kind of
empathize with the plight of these
animals and their suffering she was
always an athletic little girl until she
had this terrible problem in the early
teens she started having knee pain
slightly before my teenage years I
developed a problem with my knee I was
in all sorts of pain all sorts of
trouble with it so I went in to hospital
continually having
Beckerman kneecap scraped after having
the ligaments and things registered
around my kneecaps kind of pivot in a
different direction and nothing was
really working that was about right leg
that was effective start with and then
because I was leaning so heavily on my
left leg that became weak and affected
so I was having all these surgeries it
was very very frustrating I think kind
of about 17 operations you know I was
not able to go to school I was getting
too weak to go to school I couldn't
mobilize around the school couldn't do
anything there wasn't even offered any
home tutoring and then the doctor said
look we've got a serious problem there
is a massive conglomeration behind your
kneecap it is turning it to jelly
it is crumbling inside and it needs to
come out and it needs to come out
quickly
this is gonna be a big operation and
this is gonna be very painful I have to
say I've never been in pain like I was
in after that operation I couldn't lay I
couldn't move in my bed I couldn't
couldn't literally ultimate position in
my bed I was told I wouldn't walk again
properly let alone we ever be able to do
sporting activities especially things
like running which one I in fact I was
going to be registered disabled at one
point because it looks so hopeless
so that was an incredibly challenging
time for all the family actually yeah
definitely I mean you learn from
experience that's the best way to learn
you can tell somebody something all the
time you can tell people all that race
is really hard and they probably look
into this a bit stunned and a backpack
that can't be that hard and fifty odd
degree heat but you learn from
experience that I do understand that
what I went through as a teenager is
obviously impacted me but the important
thing it hasn't made me bitter it just
made me focused on not allowing it if I
can prevent it happening to anything or
anyone else not in terms of that
suffering what happened to me it wasn't
anyone's fault it was just something but
you you learn have an embassy for yes
unnecessary suffering is just appalling
any sort of pain of any sort of creature
it's just something you just wouldn't
even want to inflict and I I don't know
I I mean it's really really hard for me
to sit here in front of an audience film
about me in fact when Keegan actually
contacted me I saw it was Martin winding
milk
trying to make you as uncomfortable as
possible it was like you know I mean why
would anyone want to make a film about
me I mean I'm just like eating you know
my Superman you can't even run ya know I
mean I know let's see if admittedly now
finally though you've convinced me
yeah I mean yeah I mean I can't I can't
yeah I mean okay you know I can run
physically a comportment one leg in
front of the other but yeah I'm not
great I am very determined you know and
I've got doing it for a reason I am
doing it for a reason and that reason is
greater than oh I've got my eye on
winning that Garmin or a TV or a place
that's of no interest to me whatsoever
in fact you go to these races and people
start talking about all things running
and utmb points and have you done that
race and they'll be done this race no
clue what they're talking about go away
from me running is about A to B as
quickly as you can get in the job done
and seeing if you can knock it on to
help animals that's another thing that
I've done I mean I've had to really work
hard for a CV that's actually made
people sit up and you know look at the
results I've got like in 2005 when I was
coming back from Amsterdam with that 8th
place and placing in the lung and
marason and the Berlin Maris and all the
big races I only used to do two
marathons a year and that was basically
because it was economical financially
and physically I didn't have to be away
from the sanctuary and I did this kind
of speaking to on a podcast today and
the lady said to me I said never even
had a massage I have no coach I've no
physio I've never had a month I was if
it hit me in the face I've literally
running charity shop closing and
obviously I've got my shoes now and you
know my shoes are very important to me
because obviously it's I have to care
for my knees but I am literally I miss
cheap a Maturana gone mad I literally am
and then all of a sudden one minute
you're running around the danger
peninsula with the only company as a
squirrel that you might see and next
minute year you being chauffeured on
this bus do these technical meetings
with all these Kenyans and Ethiopians
and they've all got the coaches and the
managers and I've got my mom we're
sitting at the back like to school
children playing noughts and crosses and
they're going out technically what do
you want to do in this race and you
thinking I just want to finish it alive
you know from getting away from being
successfully so it's a really weird
scenario that I've been coming through
but and when you're amongst these people
you realize that you're actually not
very good yourself I mean you know but
you either winging it and bluffing it
and doing what you can for the animals
but I've got no ID no particular
interesting going to the North Pole or
doing any of that I just thought you
know obviously if people say you know
they feel tired to say oh I feel like
I've run a marathon and if they say you
know it's cold out though North Pole's
I've put the two together and that's got
to be definitive front row leaders have
eaten can do anything but and that's
been the logic behind it can it be a win
for the for the animals can I get
something back in there you know
introduce because it's like creative
activism that I've had to do so if
you're going to join the fire brigade
it's introducing not at the time wasn't
introducing females to a forum that not
necessarily going to be in I was the
first female firefighter in our division
and then when it cropped up that I was
vegan as well you can see the hassle I
got from the guys they're evil but they
had to think about it they had to think
about the fact that I wasn't in a well
other fire boats so they had to import
them from Italy for me so you know that
kind of thing just gently introducing
kind of veganism and making whether
they're going to go vegan or not they've
got to be aware of it and respect it and
that's what my activism has kind of been
about
people listen to Fiona talk and they
come to me afterwards to say you must be
very proud
I said no pride reflects honour to me I
look at her in awe and then the guilt
kicks in the guilt at having brought a
life into the world which is so
compassionate and feeling loving that
she has to push herself to these
tremendous lengths to try to get a
platform so that she can speak for those
who have no voice Fiona we were chatting
a little bit before before the film
about sort of the current state of
awareness and excitement around this
movement and as somebody who's been
vegan and advocating in this space it's
Heuer 6-7 years old what's your
perspective on where the movement is now
and how do you you know think about that
yeah I mean it's really exploded and
yeah I mean every day in the UK
something new comes so every time you
turn on the media's first year with
vegan or something like that it really
has gone mad and literally it's just
growing and growing and growing and I
think people talk about the tipping
point and we I think we surely are
reaching it and what I would like to
emphasize especially to younger people
is I think they forget a pre social
media time when this just wasn't
available when I said I went vegan at 6
I didn't say to my mom I want to go
vegan I didn't even know what vegan was
it was just an ethical choice I knew
that I wanted to opt out of certain
things and I couldn't put a name to it
it was more of a feeling that I had but
now I mean obviously it's growing and I
think especially with young people it's
the youngsters that are actually
realizing this this is not just vegan
isn't just one pronged it's not just it
started with the animals for me and I'm
still learning as a vegan obviously I
didn't realize I mean cowspiracy what
the hell's have taught me a lot I just
know my bit of veganism but now it's
just growing and growing and growing
and I think young people especially are
realizing this isn't just about animals
and the hell's it's about the health of
the planet the health of those that
others who live on it and the
environment and it's scary what's
happening to the environment and it's
their future and their children's future
and they're taking hold with the
initiative they've got and the
inspiration they provide it gives me
hope because at times I've been in a
complete state of district despair
hence the cow costume you know running
doing anything you've got to do that's
why I ended up at the North Pole in the
desert because what do what you gotta do
to make people listen but now there's a
whole generation out there that can do
that successfully and that that's yes
that's massive Keagan you uh you had
your own ultra experience trying to
document this while the race was going
on by yourself right it wasn't you and a
crew of people it was just you and very
heavy camera equipment running yourself
across the desert and I'm left wondering
watching this like how did he do that
like where's keegan sleeping where is he
going how is he charging his batteries
like how is all of this working so yeah
walk us through that yeah I mean
logistically it was definitely a
challenge Kip and I my co-director of
cowspiracy what the hell I've always
done things super low budget and super
low crew people say Oh where's your crew
in Psych whoa it be just he and I and
since I solo directed this one it was
literally just me I thankfully had a
driver during marathon de Sol and about
50% maybe a little bit less of the
course is accessible by vehicle so we
would drive along he'd say I had this is
where the course is I jump out and I get
a shot but then the other half of the
time he'd say okay so you see that
mountain range go over it and then could
happen to the next valley across the
valley and there will be the course and
so it would be literally carrying my
gear go over the mountain get the shot
and then hike back over to get to the
truck sleeping in a similar camp -
Fiona's camp there's a volunteer and
staff tent area separate from from the
runners tents eating one meal a day
bringing my own food because there's not
really any offerings for vegans out
there
but it was an awesome epic adventure I
was I was doing half their distances at
times he was going quicker than we were
I did not but but I did almost die
making this movie people ask all the
time with cowspiracy and what the hell
they say you know Moe it's a
controversial film it goes up against
this big industry do you all get death
threats and off time to kind of like
joke it off like I and I but this movie
when we finished marathon ozawa
I was exhausted I've been breathing and
dust for the last two weeks running
going as hard as I could not really
taking care of myself and I flew to
South Africa the next couple days
afterwards to go speak in an event and I
contracted a horrible respiratory
infection to the point that I had to be
hospitalized and had a sustained fear of
110 plus for number of days
hallucinating didn't know who I was
didn't know where I was so I got to do
my own little adventures well right glad
that happened after the exams not before
right yeah so I want to make this
interactive and and open this up to
participation and and questions from the
audience
thank you but but before I do that one
last thing Keegan what do you like what
is what is it that you want the audience
to take from Fiona's story and and this
movie that you've made I want everybody
to feel inspired I want people to see
Fiona's challenges and everything she's
accomplished in despite all the
hindrances that she's faced both from
physically the fact that media doesn't
want to give her the attention she
deserves on and on and on I want people
to see that and be inspired to do
whatever their challenges whatever their
marathon is their Marathon asado but to
also be inspired to say I have to do
something bigger than myself
that a life of services has so much
value and so much importance and
something I think we really need in this
world and and for our own selves as well
that we'll having more fulfilling
meaningful lives when we do things for
others versus just for ourselves
and then secondarily I want everybody to
say vegan doesn't hold you back from
anything and in fact it might make you
better at what you want to do
beautifully put
alright let's uh let's open this up I'm
just gonna take this one right here at
the top this is a question for Fiona
have you ever had conversations about
your diet with other non vegan athletes
during your many races and did they or
anybody make this switch after talking
with you yeah I have conversations with
other runners I mean a best way of
answering them is not wasted breast just
go out and beat em you know I mean then
then you've answered all the questions
cuz I've been in the longer races you do
get time more time to talk and people
there are always curious and how they
can improve their performance and if
they see you doing better than them
they're interested in the diet because
that was another thing about going out
to this activism and promotion of
veganism through sport you've kind of
got a captive audience there that are
interested in performance they're
interested in ways of improving their
performance so they want to know if
you're better than them or perceived to
be better than them they'll ask how you
got better than them but yeah we it's
been cut it sounds kind of I don't and
conceited to say it but if you are
actually just performing better than
them they not so negative towards what
you're doing they might say oh you won't
be able to sustain that long on a vegan
diet so it will ratchet for forty other
years though you know I mean at how long
I'm gonna be me coughing before you
finish you know that right but you know
and it is them I've had a lot of people
in fact the tent that I shared with
there they were a really good bunch of
guys weren't they
and not none of them have gone full
vegan but a lot of like very proud
telling me that I found vegan ice cream
in Kuwait Fiona and yeah if I come and
stay with you at the new sanctuary you
know I'm quite prepared to eat vegan for
the whole week so you know and one of
the biggest wins is Elizabeth Barnes who
the MDS runner she has she was not been
well since for about a year
and she's switched vegan now and she
said she she feels amazing she's getting
the miles back in the legs now when
she's hoping to go back to MDS next year
and she puts that definitely down to
being plant-based yeah that's great
the next question has to do with with
balancing everything how do you balance
you're running the sanctuary your
relationship I know you're always in a
hurry and maybe two maybe to kind of
embark on answering that question like
take us through a day in the life from
waking up in the morning to go into bed
Wow
we got a palmistry every morning and
then whatever needs doing I do it's a
changes seasonally obviously because
there's different jobs to do in the
winter cuz I've got a lot of larger
animals we've got 76 horses
I've got 121 pigs we've got 22 cows so
they it's better to deal with those in
the daylight hours so if it's in the
winter I'll do more of the jobs that I
can do indoors or in stables and then
I'll go out to do them how I balance it
is I literally don't start Paul day I
have this one meal a day thing going on
you know everybody says I just eat one
meal a day and I get up in the morning
and I work right through and I just
don't stop I never sit down and never do
anything but work and it's kind of I
kind of I can't have recovery time so
but my idea of a recovery time would be
we have this we have this food donation
program from big supermarkets Sainsbury
where they donate their bread and
vegetables for the pigs to eat but it
has to be unwrapped
so if I've come back from a 20 mile run
the only opportunity I'm gonna have to
rest my legs is to sit in the middle of
all these bags of bread and unwrapped
them so that will be my recovery period
like an hour sitting on wrapping the
bread and then if I've got a bit of
paperwork to do that will give me some
recovery if I've been outside shoveling
or whatever I'm doing balancing it is
it's not difficult for me because the
animals always come first the training
is very secondary to running the
sanctuary and regarding my relationship
well I don't know where that one but you
know I mean I'll tell you now
Martin and I of
been at that sanctuary now for 22 years
and we've never been out together
anywhere in fact Keegan took me out for
me looking and showing some grounds and
I'm sitting there looking at this menus
or what liminal exactly I don't know
what this means this isn't nonsensical
to me because people do ask me what do
you eat I don't literally eat pig food I
don't go to a farm you know distributor
and say can I have a bag of pig food and
open it and stick my head in it
but because we're in this donation
program they give us that on date
vegetables so I'm not going to be like
sitting in the middle of my bread
unwrapping it and the vegetables and
think oh I must go and fetch some
bananas that's going to take half an
hour and like 5 pounds in money I will
literally eat those bananas and that's
basically what I live on the donated on
date vegetables pig food so last night
yeah let me just clarify your last night
at the restaurant oh yeah well that's
the first time you've been to a
restaurant since remember going to one
before we got the century so I mean it's
not definite 22 years 22 years yeah
although there's not a lot of like
Netflix and chill now there is no going
down to the pub and like so what do you
do like how do you relax do you you
can't just go go go go go all the time
I'll tell you now when I've been
training for marcin's no word of a lie
the meal that I've had it now I've had
to have it in bed and I've fallen asleep
with it hanging out my mouth sometimes
honestly I'm not tired but you know I
get up the next morning I recover I go
out the animals need me and and the
training is voluntary I just want to
give 100% I'm not going to go out there
and give 90% because that's just not
what's going the energy it takes to run
well takes a it's it's no point I'm not
out there recreationally it's great if
you are but I'm not so I'm doing it for
a purpose it's part of what I do with a
sanctuary plant parcel of me so it's a
hundred percent and that takes a lot of
energy to give a hundred percent and
that's fine I'm not looking for people
to feel sorry for me it's my choice
nobody's got a gun to my head I want to
do this I want to do as much as I can
before I die cause let's say you're a
long time dead you can't come back he
can't
you can't I don't want to look with
regrets and think I should have done
that I shoulda done that I've done the
maximum I drank genuinely can't I don't
know I could have done a lot more where
does this drive come from
it drives come from suffering it's
really strange to say it rocks to
position when I left to come here
yesterday morning
we left a sanctuary it's beautifully
tranquil it's someone's just coming up
in the dawn and the cattle and the
horses grazing in these beautiful fields
not a care in the world and I got in the
car coming to Heathrow and a slaughter
cattle transporter a double load him one
and then one saw a sheep transporter and
it just wrecked me because why aren't
those animals having what my animals
have got why do they have to suffer like
that and you feel so helpless at this
hopeless situation that you're facing
and that drives me it's not it's not
right injustice drives me and that's
injustice in the extreme towards our
fellow creatures so yeah and I'm happy
to do it and I'm just I always look back
and think I'm blessed to be able to do
it and I will say that the years of a
mobility I had about six years of him in
mobility and I've got a funny shape for
my running I've got very defined kind of
upper body and very strong in my upper
body and people say oh you do weights
you know no no I can kind of line so yes
clue and it's probably the years that
I've spent on crutches I mean my legs
were in plaster for so many years and I
don't I don't sound awful I'm gonna say
this in gross woman I don't grow hairs
on my leg I've got no I've got no I'm
completely bald on my legs because my
legs were always in plaster it killed a
dose and so I've you know it's it's it
wasn't easy to be 13 14 15 and I wanted
to be outside and literally going back
to the hospital and mean no
weight-bearing and in a lot of pain and
I will say at this time when I was
introduced to hospital that's when my
mum was accused of trial cruelty because
the diet flagged up and it was
considered to be an eating disorder
I mean veganism an eating disorder but I
get people write to me now and say the
same thing you know doctors health
professionals saying you know it's it's
not healthy and you know even when I've
come back from races you know and I've
worn them a lady died on Everest sadly
and BBC rang me and asked me for a quote
and I'm thinking why don't I send about
it I've been in Namibia anyway I didn't
know her didn't ya know she was a vegan
so I don't know every vegan on the plane
I don't six of those in the world and I
knew her well she died on Everest do you
think that's cause she was a vegan and I
said no I think it's cuz Everest is a
very dangerous place to be
whether you're a vegan or not and fully
enough the guy that had helped me get
through the race in the Atacama Bostick
he died on Everest and he who definitely
wasn't a vegan you know so to speak but
people always say you know one child in
Italy is found malnourished she was a
vegan as a reason you know they ignore
all you know the children out there that
a malnourished and you know Abby's and
whatever it's just got me that one kid
who's vegan and then all these are the
same but it's that press are very very
quick still to jump on the negativity
rather than the positivity but that's
what drives to me I don't care how tired
I am because in that race I will say you
know it's hard as brutal are you going
along no it's true but at the end of it
can't be that terrible that you can just
put your hand up and say actually I've
had enough now can I go back to camp you
and you can if you want you're not gonna
because you know you desperately want to
complete it and get the medal but you
know and I know and even don't I'm
reluctant to say I know what suffering
is because you've always I've always got
options animals haven't got options and
and that's what drives me I know that
and I know that yeah it's pretty
insignificant what I do but I'm looking
to be able to do it I'm afraid to ask
the next part of this question because
I'm afraid your your your advice is not
going to be good the the question is
advice for dealing with injury no no I'm
not I'm not I'm not I'm not how you deal
with injury well I'm not sure well
sometimes I go out running sometimes and
I feel so bad I actually think I'm
either gonna get through this in one
piece I'm just gonna drop dead he has
pushed me out the door to go I'm along
on Sunday and I've been crying and I've
contemplated seriously we live up and
say a bridal pass running up there
giving it all the Fate and then going up
there and just sitting down for two
hours and then coming back so I've done
it but you never do when you get out
there you know you rise them I wouldn't
say I would run through an interest this
that I've got with money it's a
manageable pain I know how to deal with
that it you know I can deal with that I
wouldn't call that an injury I wouldn't
tell people to get out there and boost
it till it hurts if it doesn't drop off
you're all right I once I wouldn't say
that
I'd probably do it myself to say but
that's not what I would vibe I can give
out great advice I just don't take it
you know all right next question how do
you start training for a race and what
would you recommend to somebody who
wants to run their first marathon just a
road Morrison just build up gradually
and sustaining you haven't got to be
that faster when I was trying to explain
something you haven't got to be that
fast to run a sub to 40 Morrison you've
only it's only just like ten mile an
hour or whatever you just got to be able
to sustain it for a long period of time
so I would say build gradually and don't
go into it all that oh yeah I could do
40 miles today because you're gonna get
injured don't do too much build up
gradually that's what I do with all my
training I am NOT that flamboyantly good
runner but I can sustain it over a ten
week period I can sustain a training
program that's going to get me through
100 miles a week and for me the
testament to the time you can run on
race day is only a testament to the
amount of training your body will allow
you to do in when you're actually
building up to the event and that's the
pure testament of a vegan diet the
recovery you've got to be able to
recover very quickly to run two sessions
a day
Howard sessions and to keep doing it
week in week out it's no good doing it
one week and then be you know ripped
apart and flatten you back the next
you've got to be able to do it very very
gradually and don't don't overload don't
stress about times just get familiar
with the distance my motto is if you
don't train hard you won't race hard and
I do have some weird training going on
like
if I run to up to 20 miles I never take
water with me I won't allow myself water
that's just out over the world places I
can get water a long route but I like to
make it as hard as I can because I sure
as hell gonna be hard on the day and
yeah but consistency yeah consistency is
all-important yeah yeah you know
managing the miles and doing the speed
where if you want to run it if you would
want to get round a Morrison just become
familiar with the the mileage you've got
to do if you want to run a marathon
quickly you've got a speed worker and
you've got a new hard speed work so you
have this background in track cycling
yeah yeah
so that preceded the running yeah I've
never heard you talk about it but you
can see your bikes a couple times in in
the movie do you still ride and how did
that that career inform your running
career yeah I mean cycling it's very
very good exercise if you can't impact
that's why I took cycling I've been
cycling before my injuries and I went
back to cycling because it's just
low-impact and it's just straightforward
you know exercise that I could do quite
easily the reason I packed up with the
cycling I've ridden all around the world
by tracing on the road and the track
it's before bat racing became so popular
we didn't have much of a bike racing
program in the UK till sort of early
noughties so I just did cycling because
it was something that I knew my body
would probably allow me to do and he did
to a certain extent the reason I packed
he took was it's very time consuming you
got me out there four or five hours a
day if you want to do well on the road
if you want to do well on the track
you've got to go to a track and train
there isn't one near me there's not one
for miles
it's expensive to buy it's the equipment
it just wasn't for me when we moved to
the sanctuary we didn't have a penny we
didn't have anything and I said I don't
have the time I just thought you know
and I was running two hours running a
day that's plenty but you know four
hours and bike maintenance but I don't
bother riding my bike now I tend to just
train running I don't actually I could
say I do but I don't really do much
cross-training I just run can we get you
some help with the sanctuary
thank you we get some people
to help you out so you don't have to
wake up at 3 o'clock in the morning
every day yeah we could would you accept
that help yeah if people wanted to come
to the sanctuary and help out if they
wanted to come they would be welcome to
come and help yeah it's hard running a
sanctuary because unless people are
gonna come regularly they've got
familiarized yourself with the animals I
never wanted the sanctuary to become an
institutional kind of place where you've
got lots of animals and it's just Oh put
that horse in number 23 stable and I'll
be down very soon it was I want it's a
family we are a family and he can carry
Manisa do you know that horse and of
course I know them all by name I know
every nuance of every action they do and
I can walk down that yard and I can yeah
he's probably waiting for me to come
home and say something like what's wrong
with angel it's a big Friesian horse so
I don't know I'd noticed and I know
everything about everything just from
the way the standing I can tell it's
gotta be somebody that comes that's
willing to invest and learn like that
because I think that running the
sanctuary as I do
you've got to preempt problems and
that's what I like prevention rather
than cure for the animals and it's also
a very tranquil environment for them I
don't want lots of people coming in and
upsetting them and because a lot of them
are very heavily traumatized I mean
we've had we've had everything at
Sanctuary I mean it's very horrible to
say a pro shooting everything from dogs
that have been raped heavily you know
you get all sorts come in there it's not
the pretty side of animal rescue but
it's the real side of it so yeah I would
welcome help obviously I would welcome
help if people wanted to come and spend
time there yeah yeah this is something
I've talked to gene Baur about you know
specifically the fact that you have to
come into this awareness that you're not
going to be able to save all of these
animals that your heart is in the right
place you do the best that you can you
tend to these these these beings that
are under your care but also trying to
find a way to make it sustainable
because just like your training it's
about consistency like and I just I fear
like I see your schedule and I was like
how do you avoid burning out like how do
you manage this gigantic load and
shoulder this
you know for such a long period of time
without something not just breaking down
in you I think the thing to break down
is there mentally that's where you're
vulnerable bodily less so you know
mentally but I am very very mentally
strong and I've got a very firm reason
of why I'm doing what I'm doing and some
people say to me it must be easier for
me because you're amongst the animals
all the time so you see the results or
the rewards of what you're doing and
that is true to a certain extent but on
the other side of the coin it's really
heartbreaking because you see how
individual certain animals are for
instance I can never understand how
people in the world people all over it
certainly Western world they seem to do
on their dogs and their cats but they
don't even have a sort for a pig or a
sheep or a cow
it seems really strangely I for instance
one night it was really really hot and
we've got this massive load of
watermelons that have been donated from
the Sainsbury so I said oh let's take
them over to the pigs or watermelons and
bananas and give them a treat so we went
over there and so there was all squeals
of delight and it was Sun setting and
they were in their mud baths and piggies
ran out and you know some wanted bananas
and wanted watermelon some took
watermelons and they decided wanted
bananas and they're all bringing around
joyous you know and he's thinking these
are individual souls it just shows that
they do have preferences these guys they
feel very much as we feel and that's
what's very inspiring about that race to
marys and estar but you could just take
it as a tough race so dinner party
conversation look at what this Medellin
I've done MDS but you could take it as a
life-changing experience and when we're
all strip back actually to the bare
essentials like in the desert if you're
out there you're running and somebody
offered you a big gold bar for instance
something that you cover in in you know
in in civvy Street you say no thank you
it's too heavy to carry
it's like that kind of thing and you
realize that actually what is essential
whether you're human or non-human alike
is water shelter and food and not been
in fear and pain they're the really
important things in life the material
things and nothing there nothing at all
they're the things that really really
matter and that's the same for animals
as well and all animals deserve that not
people come to the sanctuary and say Oh
aren't your animals lucky and I say no
they're just having what there is there
right they're being afforded their
rights doesn't it you shouldn't be look
involved in it it should be there for
all animals but it's only there for a
few this next question is teed up for
Keegan Keegan what is the biggest single
issue facing the world today come on
a lot of people won't like this one yeah
yeah the biggest issue facing the world
today is humanity that's the reality of
it the world has been for three billion
years doing all right
it goes through all these different
cycles but we're in this largest mass
extinction planet seen in 65 million
years
that's human caused to many of us
wanting to live a western lifestyle
that's a problem it's a very solvable
problem we can abstain from having
children we can adopt a plant-based diet
and we can choose to voluntarily lower
our standard of living
everybody in the world can't live at the
standard of living that we have in the
in the West and we've got to be real
realistic about that on that we've got a
lower our standard of living to meet the
rest of the world so there is more
equality that's probably not the answer
they wanted either I didn't have a
desire for you to answer one way or the
other than completely honestly did I
have a quick question for you the last
time that we spoke on the podcast was on
the cusp of what the health coming out
and we haven't sort of reconvened since
then so I'm interested in what that
experience has been like
obviously the response to that movie was
extraordinary I really think that it
impacted culture in a very substantial
way and so how did you know how do you
think about the impact that the movie
has had and and how does that affect or
not affect how you advocate on behalf of
the things that are important to you
if the response to what the health has
been phenomenal I mean it just totally
blew me away and I think for Kip
Anderson as well my co-director on that
film it's been amazing how people have
received that film and digested it and
implemented into their own lives of
changing their lifestyle you know
whether going 100% vegan or just
eliminating a lot of animal products
from their diet the backlash that that
film has gotten was wasn't as surprising
to be honest that we knew while making
that film that there was gonna be hard
push back to this to the information
that's in the film because it shines a
light on a lot of things that a lot of
people don't want to look at the role
that large chemical agriculture places
in our food the role that pharmaceutical
industry plays in our healthcare the
role that the meat and dairy industry
plays in Health Organisation's a lot of
people don't want that talked about and
they don't want to hear it
so the negative response that the film
got was a little bit more expected but
it's done a lot to promote the film
because people say oh have you heard
about that BS film what the hell no I
haven't those you go check that out
those guys are liars yeah they're liars
so how do you do you how do you choose
or choose not to engage in that
conversation whether it's online or in
media yeah my response is always very
simple are we make science-based film's
fact-based films every single statistic
stat and reference in the film is
referenced on our website what the
health film comm cowspiracy comm as well
there's a resource page that has
literally every single source so you can
see the original studies so you can look
up and you can decide for yourself
whether it's true or not I'm not a
scientist on journalists essentially so
I'm presenting the information that's
available you guys all saw cowspiracy
and what the health yeah it's Kip here I
thought I saw him earlier you might dip
down yeah there he is he's waving so Kip
Anderson is here give him a shout out as
well so we got to wrap this up two
questions first how and when
can people who are listening to this or
watching it on YouTube how can they see
the movie yeah so the film will be
released shortly we're working on some
final legal things to get it out but it
released online hopefully by middle to
end of September it'll also be available
for theatrical screenings and community
organized screenings and then we'll see
where it goes from there but the feeling
is is that when we get the speaking
community behind a film just like we saw
with cowspiracy what the health
it gives it legs way beyond to any
distributor and then when we get the
running world behind it when we get the
female athletics behind it when we get
everybody who lives their life with a
mission behind it then this film has the
ability to get really out there into the
world yeah are you taking it on the road
are you gonna go visit the running
communities and do screenings I'm
exhausted I don't have I'm already
working on another movie so I mean this
woman who can't even really run yeah
Fiona how can people I mean you're the
portrayal of you in the movie and the
work that you do is inspiring and it
demonstrates a level of dedication to a
cause that we don't typically see in our
lives like it's it's it's really
incredible the love and the dedication
and the devotion that you have to the
things that that are important to you
and so when you see this movie if people
are listening to this you'll know what
I'm talking about
and I'm sure there's a lot of people out
there who who would like to support you
who would like to help you who would
like to lift you up so for those people
where can they go how can they help how
can they contribute we go website Oh
Tower Hill stables org and they can get
details on there and about how to donate
and things like that but the main thing
I want from my life honestly
obviously I need security I need I don't
want any money from anyone in terms of
for me it's everything we've ever had
that the sanctuary goes directly to the
animals my partner is only just when he
took early retirement to actually stay
at the sanctuary and and look after the
animals when I'm away a little bit more
the main thing people can do is if they
want to help financially that's great
because I don't want worry about the
vets and the feed merchants and
everybody else do want vast sums of
money to make this happen the most thing
is that they can be the best vegan they
can be if you can and go out there and
promote veganism that's what my life is
is more about now just making the world
see what I can see and if they want help
from the sanctuary that's amazing and
where can they go to do that it's the
main tower Hill stables page that like a
donate options and it's not just like
donate money but it's time and raise
awareness and do a little fund raisers
and things out there's loads of things
that people can do it's not just
necessarily some money obviously money
is fantastic because I've constantly got
people beating my door to get money you
know well it's they feed much foreign
merchants you're always listening on the
television you know we've had a bit of
hot weather in the UK and suddenly all
forage is going to be short or winter
and it's going to be about 300 pounds a
bale of hay and you know animals gonna
have to be cold so no it's going to be a
disaster but yeah through the through
the website is the best place and if
anybody contacts to me I mean I've
always you know they're understand
through my mails and they want to ask
you know can we do a little fundraiser
for you or people do all sorts of things
like Kate Bates and sponsors and
silencers and name the teddy you know
lots of things that innovative ways and
you know and just spread the word about
the sanctuary because there might be
other people out there that want to help
that's the main thing that can do I'm
not that good at asking for things from
people to be honest with what I'm asking
for you yeah
and what do you what kind of crazy world
record are you chasing next well what
I'm gonna do is I'm doing the Atacama
crossing I thought I'll just go back to
the Atacama Desert and do weak state why
not why not and then after that because
I'll be in pretty good shape probably
break the world record for the fastest
woman trying a marathon in Macau sue
because I can do that in the UK because
it'll be do
and you get more interest oh and then
run a championship qualifying for London
so that's got just a list of three
marason but that'd be quite good in a
County because I'm quite quite a novelty
saying and then I go back to the
Morrison to sample next year hopefully
with my new shoes and they don't fall to
pieces on me and I can actually hit it
hard or harder and if people want to
check out your shoes work and they out
there at Will's vegan shoes if you look
at wills vegan shoes they will design
these actually the terrible plight of
what happened in the desert and they are
actually really really good for trail
running they're really robust I reckon
I've got about five Maris endure samples
in these so don't tell Martin because I
think I'm going back for the next five
years but yeah these are really
excellent and you can find him at Will's
feet and shoes in the UK you know so
find them on our website the running for
film running for good film DOM and the
amazing thing about these shoes is that
30% of the sales goes directly to the
sanctuary so oh that's cool yeah that's
a great way for people is there the as
far as I know they're the world's first
carbon-neutral sweatshop free
intentionally vegan trail running shoe
hmm and then again 30% of it goes to the
animals directly yeah
Fiona you need to hire this guy as your
publicist I made a whole movie about
Keegan let's wrap this up with can you
can you talk about what's next for
you and what you're working on
yeah so I'm working on a new film called
hungry for justice which is a food
justice documentary with my friend John
Louis the badass vegans a former guest
on ritual podcast and it follows John on
this journey looking at the link between
diet disease poverty institutionalized
racism government corruption and so much
more because it's really G on on this
journey he's originally from Ferguson
Missouri which unfortunately has always
been an impoverished and violent
community and he's seen the disease and
that's rampant there and so he's looking
to answer this question why is it that
Americans of color suffer from
disproportionately higher rates of
chronic disease diabetes heart disease
and cancer and then once those people
are diagnosed why are they more likely
to die from those diseases than
Caucasian Americans
so it's a deep film looking at the role
of institutionalized racism in medicine
the historical implication of the
colonial diet a Western diet that's been
pushed on communities of color but it
does that through the lens of hip-hop so
we're interviewing and highlighting
influential hip-hop artists and R&B
artists who are plant-based or vegan or
talk about food consciousness because
arguably hip-hop is the most influential
art form in human history what hip-hop
artist where say do drive eat drink and
talk about influences in the purchasing
power of millions of people around the
world so when these people start talking
about the importance of healthy eating
of veganism of being conscious of what
you put in your body they have the
ability to truly change this world
so it's shaping up to be a really
powerful film we're about halfway
through shooting and I hope to have that
out probably this time next year trying
to do a feature every year yeah awesome
can I before you close it I want to
thank you so much rich for all of your
support of the film for all of our films
that we've done you have been so
generous with your time to be narrator
for the film which I feel incredibly
indebted to you for for doing this event
tonight
I think 98% of the people who are here
would have shown up without a movie
screening just the fact that rich roll
was doing it
and I really appreciate you all coming
but I feel it's so indebted to you for
that I'm so grateful to Chris Swan to
everybody a side show who helped put on
this event to Jason the fact that
actually probably 80% of the people
involved in making this movie which is a
very short list are here tonight we give
a shout out to Jason he's our the
composer Jason stand up this is Jason
camiolo he is
the audio engineer for the podcast but
he's also the composer of the music in
the film tonight which which the the
score for the film is like the third
character to me it's Fiona it's the
desert and then it's the music to Amon
Stewart who did the animations all the
maps he's an extremely talented big
shout-out to him
Sasha Perry my co-editor unfortunately
had a dip out early
Jim Greenbaum who's one of our executive
producers incredible guy Greg Anzalone
unfortunate can't be here tonight
incredible supporter unbelievable bent
over backwards to promote this film
there's so many people but again I just
I feel so thankful to you rich for using
your platform to highlight people's
stories you again give voice to so many
people who don't have a larger voice and
just deeply appreciative and I think
everybody else here who's a fan of the
show is deeply appreciative for where
you do well I appreciate that thank you
it's an honor and a privilege to be able
to share a message as potent and
powerful as the message that both of you
are putting out in the world so thank
you for having a message and allowing me
to share it and I think that's it and we
did it how do you feel
Fiona how you feel you ready to go to
our restaurant it's past your bedtime
anybody you didn't want to come and
spend time looking at this it's really
it you know yeah
talking to the mic yes all right let's
hear it for Fiona and for Keegan and for
everybody who's here tonight who
supported or helped create this
beautiful movie support this movie tell
your friends share it on social media
support independent cinema and I am
eager to do more live events and
hopefully I will be doing more of this
kind of stuff so I'll let you guys know
and I really appreciate everybody who
came out tonight on a weeknight to spend
some time with us so thanks to all of
you for coming
peace peace you say it take us out
plants done
[Applause]
[Music]
you